les glandes du jour appelle la question
orale de monsieur bruno sido à monsieur
me de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame la garde des sceaux
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
chers collègues ma question madame la
ministre s'est adressé à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur je suis ravi que
vous soyez si bien entendu et concerne
les opportunités de coopération entre
les conseils généraux et les services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
plus communément appelée 10 comme
secrétaire général de l'assemblée des
départements de france adf et président
du conseil général de la haute-marne je
mesure au quotidien les possibilités de
mutualisation entre les conseils
généraux et les 10 alors que la
situation financière du pays est
difficile c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire optimiser l'organisation du service
public en concevant des modalités de
coopération plus audacieuses constitue
un véritable enjeu pour l'avenir de nos
politiques publiques est en effet
l'objectif de la mutualisation et de
faire mieux avec autant de moyens
mobilisés concrètement en haute-marne
dans le respect de l'autonomie et des
spécificités du sdiss est à un niveau de
service public égal le conseil général
met à disposition plusieurs agents en
tout ou partie de leur temps de travail
pour remplir les missions qui nous sont
communes je pense notamment à
l'élaboration du technique du budget à
la comptabilité à l'intendance au marché
public ou encore au service juridique
cette dynamique de mise en commun des
compétences et de partage d'informations
atteint cependant ses limites
nous intervenons en effet dans le cadre
du décret du 18 juin 2008 qui fixe le
régime des mises à disposition pour les
agents des collectivités territoriales
et des établissements publics
nous souhaitons aller plus loin en
créant de véritables services unifiés
commun au conseil général et aux 10 je
veux bien entendu parler de
mutualisation
l'article 68 de la loi du 16 décembre
2010 prévoit la possibilité de créer je
cite un service unifié ayant pour objet
d'assurer en commun des services
fonctionnels fermez les guillemets en
créant l'article 5100
11-1-1 du code général des collectivités
territoriales
seulement madame la garde des sceaux
madame la ministre cette évolution
suppose la signature d'un décret en
conseil d'état nous avons déjà évoqué
avec monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
cette question il y a quelques mois si
le gouvernement partage cette
orientation attendu par de nombreux
conseils généraux à quel moment ces
dispositions seront elles prises je vous
remercie par avance madame la garde des
sceaux de préciser que vous pourrez
m'apporter une réponse
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame christiane taubira garde des
sceaux ministre de justice
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur sido je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence de manuel valls ou savez ce
que sont nos vies personnellement en ce
moment je suis moi même remplacé à
l'assemblée nationale pour être
présentes ici je suis donc chargé de
vous communiquer la réponse de mon
collègue ministre de l'intérieur dont
vous l'avez interrogé sur les
possibilités de m'utiliser de
mutualisation entre les services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
et les conseils départementaux je vous
ai écouté très attentivement et
d'ailleurs enfin de question je vous
dirai à quoi je m'engage moi
personnellement étant chargé de vous
apporter cette réponse alors on m'a
chargé de vous communiquer une réponse
extrêmement savante je suis sûr que vous
avez l'essentiel de ce que je vais vous
dire en votre qualité de président de
conseil général
mais je communique ces informations
parce qu'elles vont éclairer l'assemblée
et bien entendu les citoyens qui sont
toujours extrêmement attentif à nos
travaux donc il vous est rappelé
l'article l 13 11 2 du code général des
collectivités territoriales en fait
l'esprit de la réponse consiste à
rappeler toute une série de dispositifs
législatifs ou réglementaires qui
permettent déjà une bonne coopération de
bonne mutualisation de des services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
et des conseils généraux des services
départementaux je ne doute pas
d'ailleurs que les présidents de conseil
général sur l'ensemble du territoire
hexagonal et des outre-mer veille à
optimiser les finances publiques par l'
usage de ces dispositions donc ce
premier article concerne permet de
conclure des baux emphytéotiques
administrative vous le savez en vue de
construire des casernes donc je n'ai pas
plus loin puisque cela relève de la loi
de finances rectificative de 2005 qui a
été prolongée vous le savez jusqu'au 31
décembre 2013 donc c'est une disposition
qui peut être encore utiliser cette
année il vous est également rappelé
l'article 14 24 1 du code de général des
collectivités territoriales encore qui
rappelle que toute convention ayant
trait à la gestion non opérationnels du
sdiss peut-être dans passé avec le
conseil général et ce sont des
conventions pluriannuelles
la loi du 26 octobre 2009 relative au
transfert des départements des parcs de
l'équipement a également ouvert au
département a la possibilité d'effectuer
pour le comté à la demande du sdiss
l'entretien de l'ensemble de ses moyens
matériels et notamment su assurant des
missions d'intervention et de sécurité
civile ensuite étant donné que vous
mentionnez l'antique de 51 11 1 du même
code qui est créée par la loi du 16
décembre 2010 cette disposition marquent
en effet une nouvelle étape dans les
possibilités de mutualisation
puisqu'elle permet aux 10 et aux
conseils généraux de procéder par
convention une mutualisation de certains
services fonctionnels à vocation
technique ou administrative toutes
choses que vous avez par ailleurs j'en
suis absolument sûr les conventions
conclues entre les départements et les
régions leurs établissements publics
leurs groupements et les syndicats
mixtes prévoit soit la mise à
disposition de services du service et
des équipements d'un des cocontractants
soit le regroupement des services et
équipements existants de chaque
cocontractant alors j'ai toute une série
d'autres articles je vais juste vous les
mentionner en parlant de celui qui
évoque la possibilité de se doter d'un
service unifié ayant pour objet
d'assurer en commun des services
fonctionnels administratifs ou
techniques
ainsi que celui de janvier 2012
relatif aux modalités de calcul de
remboursement des frais de
fonctionnement mais ayant été attentive
à
épouser rappeler que tout cela est fait
sans remettre en cause l'équilibré
institutionnel actuel m'ayant été
attentive à la formulation de votre
question j'ai bien entendu que votre
préoccupation majeure concerne la
publication du décret qui doit être pris
en conseil d'état je n'ai pas d'éléments
de réponse dans ce qui m'a été
communiquée ce que je peux vous dire et
c'est mon engagement personnel je verrai
je verrai dès aujourd'hui avec manuel
valls pour obtenir une réponse sur les
délais probable de publication de ce
décret en conseil d'état et voulait
faire parvenir et je porterai je
pousserai le scrupule jusqu'à m'assurer
que cette information vous êtes vous est
parvenu transmise par écrit sinon je
veillerai moi-même a voulu la faire
parvenir dans les meilleurs délais merci
le ministre monsieur bruno sido si vous
voulez oui très rapidement je madame la
ministre madame la garde des sceaux je
vous remercie pour votre réponse je sais
que vous êtes presque le pilot de mai
d'ailleurs je suis très heureux que ce
soit la garde des sceaux qui ministre de
la justice finale du final qui me
répondent parce que au fond j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être reçu avec d'autres par
le président de la république monsieur
hollande et je lui ai parlé de ce sujet
et il m'a dit la loi c'est la loi même
l'état doit la respecter alors je ne
peux pas tombée sur meilleure personne
pour faire respecter la loi vous
comprenez c'est vrai tout ce que vous
m'avez dit je lirai avec attention la
réponse qui me parviendra par écrit
parce que je je je consulterai tous tous
les articles mais cette amende 7 ce
décret que nous attendons simplifierait
tout est à l'heure où les collectivités
doivent faire des économies puisque
l'état lui-même diminue ses dotations
aux collectivités ce décret très attendu
par toutes les collectivités journée